welcome everyone and thank you for
joining us for today's keynote
presentation extracellular vesicle
mediated mRNA base gene delivery for
targeted treatment of her2 positive
breast cancer in mice by Pro drugs a new
gendell delivered enzyme pro drug
therapy presented by dr. AC man
professor of microbiology and immunology
department of microbiology and
immunology Stanford University School of
Medicine
my name is Xavier courtiers and I will
be your moderator for today's event
we're delighted to bring you this
educational web seminar presented by lab
roots lab roots is the leading
scientific social networking website and
producer of educational virtual events
and webinars now before we begin I would
like to remind everyone that this event
is interactive we encourage you to
participate by submitting as many
questions as you want during the
presentation simply click on the ask a
question box located on the far left
view screen and type your questions into
the drop down box our speaker will
respond to your questions via email
following the presentation if you have
trouble seeing or hearing the
presentation please click on the ask a
question box to let us know that you're
experiencing a problem
this presentation is educational and
those offers continuing education
credits please click on the continuing
education credits tab located in the top
right corner of the presentation window
and follow the process to obtain your
credits now without further ado please
join me in welcoming dr. Mann I will now
turn the presentation over to him thank
you very much for your introduction and
to the audience you just heard the topic
of my presentation so I wouldn't repeat
it this is a collaborative effort that
has engaged several members of my own
group whose names appear under my name
ac medicine and it also includes several
Stanford scientists for example dr.
Pedram and others that are mentioned in
on the slide as well as extra Stanford
Stanford Research Institute and Exo
Terra dr. Alaine del care has been
involved and local company systems
Biosciences and also in the course of
this research me received quite a bit of
feedback from NIH intramural scientists
and their name are listed by their
doctors table who Rodriguez and wantings
so first background on core drugs that
have been used for treating cancer Pro
drugs are compounds that are harmless in
their native state but they can become
they do become highly toxic
when activated by a bacterial or viral
enzyme so then you know if you could
confine the capability to generate that
enzyme to the tumor then you have a
situation where you can have off-site
free therapy only that the tumor would
be harmed when the pro drug is
administered because it's only the tumor
that can activate it and that you know
if done properly will overcome the
serious issue of most of the
conventional therapeutic approaches
which you all know not only kill the
cancer cells but cause a great deal of
off-site toxicity which is highly
uncomfortable and terrible
so the 2g devs have been tested in
clinical trials and I'll give you a
brief introduction brief description of
them so one of them is called Jen secret
and this is activated by a viral enzyme
high meaning kinase one which
converts it into a compound you can see
the arrow from Genesee global leading to
compound that the viral enzyme converts
upon which that compound is acted upon
by the host kinase is and converts the
the compound into an analog of guanosine
triphosphate and this analog can then
get into the DNA break apart the DNA
destroyed and kill the son so as I said
that you could confine it if you can
could confine his capability the Chu man
that would be great alright so this is
the only drug Cal acquitted regimen that
has been subjected to a phase 3 clinical
trial and this was done for glioblastoma
multiforme
patients 248 of them but involved the
gene encoding the send this activating
enzyme that's what an enzyme was
introduced using a virus and directly
into the cranium you know none of the
pro drug purchased have as yet until
argon birth which I'll describe shortly
have attempted to
systemically target the gene in all
cases the gene was delivered directly to
the cancer itself okay so this clinical
trial was conducted and the result was
there are no benefits ever seen
whatsoever another pro drug will be
called CB in 1954 or try to Zika has
been subjected to phase one two clinical
trials it is activated by a bacterial
enzyme called NTR and you know the NCR
converts it into true compound which you
can see from the arrows and one of these
compounds the
top-1 is then acted upon by one of our
metabolites which are found in all human
beings and gets converted again into a
highly toxic Ben's life and this also
has the effect of mucking up the DNA and
kill the cell so as I said it has been
subjected to phase one two clinical
trials and these results were really
quite equivocal in some cases there
seemed to be little benefit in the sense
that the THC concentration can go up as
high as in non treatment patients and
such but it really wasn't recorded as an
encouraging result and so the trial did
not proceed to the phase three stage so
what were the reasons for these failures
would be a most important reason it is
that the the amount of gene deliverance
through the target was insufficient it's
a small amount of the gene the nucleic
acid including the gene and the
expression of the gene within the target
tissue was of a short duration so this
is a major weakness or fee of this
protein synthesis founded then the
enzyme that the gene encoded the genes
encoded lacks sufficient potency and
then you know as I mentioned viruses
were used had that have their own
problems some of the monistic their
inflammation antigen again the new
rejection and another very important
factor was insufficient attention to the
eye standard effect so what is the
bystander effect okay when you try to
deliver regime to cancel through
anywhere anywhere else
none of the existing methods can convert
all the targets that can transfer all
the target cells with their gene only of
you knows a certain proportion gets
translated so to be able to kill all the
tumor cells
what you need is that the cells that do
get transfected generate enough of the
drug have capability of of converting
the pinnacle bit further into the drug
number one and number two that this drug
should be able to diffuse out of those
cells so as to be able to kill the
neighboring cells that have not been
translated so to begin with the Genesee
clover has the very poor bystander
effect but that was one of the reasons
of the call for the failure Sealy 1954
treasure seeker has a very good
bystander effect but you know in order
to properly carry out these kinds of
treatments it is necessary to know what
is the least number of cells that need
to be transfected to bring about killing
the entire tumor but no attention was
paid to this quantitative aspect of what
is the degree of transaction that is
necessary so we have paid attention to
these factors and I will not describe if
our own research so we we we have
discovered a new program and a new
activating bacterial enzyme the pro drug
is called sanam it's full chemical name
is complicated and I won't go into it
the references on this slide can take
on the barbecue the papers where the
food name is given the enzyme is chr are
and what the enzyme does is to convert
xenon which is harmless to proton into
the highly toxic drug called an CHP and
you can see that you can see the arrows
meaning from seen on to in CHP and
having examined the motivation mchb we
know that it kills cells by apoptosis
induced through the mitochondrial
pathway and how do we know it well
skipping on the slide we mentioned a few
it arrests the nuclear development in
the S phase phosphated insulin is
exposed on the surface of the membrane s
phase three is induced it could localize
it with mitochondria and Tim polarizes
the membrane potential of mitochondria
so epic ptosis is great because this
means that this drug can kill both
growing and non growing cells and that's
really important because any solid tumor
at any given time you have a significant
number of cells that are not grown and
you know not to be able to kill them is
problematic for any therapy another
important feature of nch being is that
it is highly fluorescent and the central
bar on the graph to your right
that leads to my right shows you the
high degree of fluorescence it is at 620
nanometers which means that you can
visualize it non-invasive 8 in gaming
mice so this aspect the fluorescence of
mchb
has
very helpful in our ability to further
develop this history measurement because
you know to be able to see something is
much easier than to do complicated
chemical analyses like HPLC and then
things like that which have been
necessary to characterize many other
drugs including all the programs that I
both of the protractor like that I just
mentioned so here is one example
all the magenta color that you see is
mchb fluorescence and what we did here
was to he infected a few of the cells
with the gene and the gene was carried
by a bacterium and then we found that
even though only a few cells had the
genetic capability of converting see
northern CA and CHP the magenta color is
spread out throughout the modern air and
then below that you see a
three-dimensional structure that's
called a spheroid
which is more realistic in terms of a of
a tumor and here he added something like
one to a hundred transplanted cells and
again we saw that the magenta color is
spread all over so clearly MC is being
as in as an excellent bystander effect
and you could visualize it quite easily
as a result of itself or essence even
more important and even important as I
mentioned to you it can be visualized in
little mice so we stuck to this initial
study will start to be method that had
been used before which is direct
injection or expression of gene inviting
cancer cells and you can see if you look
at the top panel of the graph on my
right there
mice can be seen the blue is the tumor
and this tumor is expressing the enzymes
thrr
and you can see that the magenta color
if you look at the third mouse to the
left of this top panel
if the magenta color is confined to the
gym now if you go to the lower part of
this slide you know three mice this is
the situation where the gene expression
was not confined to that you know it was
Express random and you can see the
magenta color is can be seen elsewhere
as well so you see this kind of thing
enables you just by observation be able
to tell how successful and approach is
the approach that you are taking in
confining the activation of the pro drug
to the tumor how you know whether
off-site activation is taking place or
not and then on the extreme right is a
demonstration but the fluorescence of
and CHP quantitatively reflects the it's
quantitatively quantified by by
fluorescence and so that's just an added
advantage and it can be gone down to is
very low that was something like two
nano grams per mil per gram of tumor
okay so if you if you take a look to the
left top crowd here again we have used
the same approach that has been used in
in the previous product regiments that
is a direct injection of the of the gene
into the tumor and so these are mice you
know which have
tumors in them and you can see if you
look at the e at the curve to the very
left then when C naught is not
administered and he administered
sing-off intravenously when it is not
administered does the mice tie all of
them died by the age of my T by day 24
or some such thing but with C knob at 10
milligram per kilogram you still have 40
percent survival at the on day 140 or so
so it's a highly effective therapy and
the rest of it is to you know
characterize what is called first
kinetics at phosphagen I mean this is
important because you need to know how
long the pro drug and the trogs stay in
the serum and in but you know what kind
of concentration they chain you know the
thing is that if the drug stays in the
in the serum under the plasma for too
long then it can affect other organs as
well now after all the drug is being
generated in the tumor but there is not
circulation it is gonna be counting and
get into the to the scenes between a
plasma and if it stays there were too
long it can hurt other organs but we
found that these things are very
favorable for this regimen there is
quick excretion of the the truck and
then we also using these data used a
special software to predict you know
whether we needed to include you know to
increase the dosage much for
effectiveness and the answer is no okay
so next is the enzyme I just described
to poor drug besides I'm B as I said we
discovered with no need as well CH along
and as I mention already one of the
factors that are who are limiting
for the success of the clinical trials
was DiLeo conducing of the activating
enzyme so we decided that we needed to
improve the strength the protein
synthesis up and for this we used all of
the cutting-edge technologies number one
is directed evolution and what you doing
directed evolution is you chop up the
gene in you know several fragments and
you let them combine at random and if
you do this with a large enough number
of fragments almost certainly you will
certainly you will reconstitute the gene
in a way that it will encode a protein
which is which has a better fit for
carrying out the reaction that you have
very interesting so you can do it by the
Ovilus called me in a sharpening or by
Arab prone PCR and as you see we have a
good screening system for the
fluorescence and so we were able to you
know examine something like six to seven
thousand gene permutations and found and
and detect those that were that encoded
important enzyme and we achieved a 213
fold improvement by this I guess
approach the second one and I won't go
too much into his detail its utilize the
statistical model that was developed at
Stanford Business School and it's really
an algorithm and it can then you by the
algorithm that can predict what change
when specific amino acid change would
lead to improvement and then in the
second round you can have further
further replacements and so we did that
and really
enhance the activity further very
considerably and finally you know the
vehicle method is x-ray crystallography
and so we did that the crystallized chri
it is Intel from Earth and within 20 to
changing a molecular weight and in this
gentleman the timers interact with each
other and the amino acids involved in
that introductional mentioned below a
lot of the distant below here the blue
highlights has a blue margin square that
you see on the slide and they are
tyrosine 128 glutamate 146 tyrosine 85
and arginine ok so the fact that
tyrosine 128 was involved really
immediately caught our attention because
we had discovered the result of the
directed evolution and tyrosine 128
conversion into asparagine had a marked
effect on the improvement of the enzyme
and so we began to reason as to why that
may be the case and if you look at it's
in Python points out here you know the
maoist cannot be seen by you but if you
look at why 128 on the dimer to your to
your left
you can see that on its oxygen atom
which is red three or four bonds
converge but if you also if you change
this tyrosine into two to the amino acid
I just mentioned couraging then what
happens is that these bonds can you know
join two different groups and the result
is strengthening of the diamond diamond
interaction not only that we also go by
chemical reasoning or able to determine
that this change would enlarge the
active site of the enzyme the exercise
contains flavin mononucleotide so having
discovered this we said okay suppose we
change all the other you know the rest
of the three amino acids that are
involved in this time of the interaction
in the same way that will further
improve the enzyme activity and as you
can see we've changed grooving for the
sixteenth trio name you can see the red
front there tyrosine 85 gets barraging
origin and 125 to the timing and all of
them further improve the activity of the
enzyme so we ended up with an enzyme
which is 100 fold which is hundred four
crates of potency then is the case with
the currently available improved NCR
enzyme which I showed you earlier was
used in clinical trial with Steve in
1954 okay so this is how we improved the
B enzyme and then we decided you know
get inside which instance were addressed
and we chose at least for our initial
studies her2 positive breast cancer
which is caused by the amplification of
the her2 gene resulting in a very high
level of expression of the her2 receptor
by the by the tumor and you know the is
something like hundred phone increased
and this is so great that if you could
use this be heard to as a target
for introducing for targeting a drug you
can really attain quite a high degree of
selectively by specific treatment and
based on this principle the monoclonal
antibodies but developed you know I
think initially by Genentech and for
example transducer man which is one of
these monoclonal antibodies turned out
to be quite effective in enhancing the
prognosis and survival of patients with
this her2 positive with this type of
cancer okay that's great but you know
side effects persist which are not
pleasant nevertheless you know it has
been a great advance however recent work
has shown you know these are clinical
studies in which something like 12,000
patients were followed for a period of
10 years and these were patients with
entreaties that transfusing that and
mature that transfuse not but in this
this study is a 10-year follow-up study
it was found then something like 25% of
things suffer from relapses and these
relapses are metastatic and not
responsive to transfusion so all of this
indicates the need for radically new
therapies to be decided to choose this
okay so as I said and all the other drug
approaches the gene was had to be put
directly into the cancer that you know
you can not be very effective you its
application can be highly limited not
all cancers are approachable you can't
see them
you can't really directly put an enzyme
or whatever on directly into the cancer
and certainly as far as metastasis is
concerned that that the thing is not
gonna work at all so it is absolutely
essential for heal effectiveness of
g-ted to be able to be able to have a
method which permits the targeting of
the cancer on systemic delivery of the
agent that is carrying the gene that we
are interested okay so as I met in the
context of the trance the vehicle that
was used for viruses and those have
really serious problems although some
want some therapies have been approved
by FDA using viruses but they you know
they can get activated in rejection
inflammation and things like that
so we decided to bypass these
conventional ways of delivering the gene
instead we used extracellular physical
which is part of my title of my talk so
what are these extracellular visitors
well the thing is that nearly all of our
body cells give out small by lipid
bilayer which entities and these are
called exons they carry with them
selected contents of the of the producer
cell the cell that is producing the
endings and they go and these contents
to locked ourselves in becoming clearer
and clearer that this intracellular
communication is very important for the
health of the body and so this also
shows that
we've eased on nature's antigens in the
new system and if so they'd like you to
be there less likely to have penetrated
and beyond responses especially if you
use V's derived from the cells of the
patient himself or herself the surface
properties of these babies are such like
attention span instinct in nine then
they can fuse with the membrane of the
recipient cell and empty their content
directly into the cytosol of the of the
discipline self and so you can have very
quick expression of whatever you are
trying to deliver that in effect and you
know they're small some 500 nanometers
and so avoid being eaten away or they
move by size they can probably lysosomes
and ends so much faster so as a result
the person what lately then other
delivery agents to reach and if they're
properly targeted to reach the intended
destination accounts systemically okay
so this is how we made our Indies and
some sound so babies are shown in here
we used head 293 cells without the
workhorse of biological search and what
you know what you do is you take it away
and by throwing they give out these
babies and then what you do you spin the
cells down there is no crevices 600
times and you move a project is
interested 2,000 times G and then
finally you spend a hundred thousand
times the differential centrifugation
and the resulting v's characterized
their size on the top left you see a
gate
this is by nano site and it tells you
that the size distribution is really
quite precise and it spans from 30 to
100 nanometers and below that our
electron micrograph so these movies and
they first of all they show really
healthy Eevee's but also another
contribution of that is that they
indicate also the same size ranges are
was found by these nano site analysis
and on the right you see the Western
analysis of these endings and they show
that they are positive for proteins that
are characteristic for EVs and their
presence identifies them as Bona
fighting Eevee so these are proteins
like say 263 CD 81 and energy in 8 so
nice nice so now we want to target them
to the cancer perk you can certainly use
the same approach that was used by the
makers of trastuzumab
we decided to move on to these be beans
ligands that could have specificity for
targeting they go to the septum and for
that we made a novel chimeric protein
you know the text in this slide tells
you how these how this protein was made
then put all very conventional
techniques so I'm not going to pretty ok
but let's concentrate on this protein
structure itself in the yellow red green
and blue the the red part represents c1
c2 domains of nectarean protein since
big fat protein and they have the
characteristic of matching
to the surface of the of the English in
front of that we cloned an S CFP with a
very high affinity for an empty her to
STF people very high affinity for the
earth to deception he also had there is
the green one and then the blue shows
you the fever sequence and this permits
the migration of this protein to the
surface of the of the evenings and the
yellow is his tech for the purification
of his book you know then you see the
the Western it's a 68 kDa protein and we
show that you know living it was only
made by cells that have been translated
with a plasmid that encodes place and
there is to the extreme left below left
is the predicted structure of this
protein the yellow part is the STF me
antibody and the blue legs there are c1
c2 so they then hatch on to the surface
of the exercise exhibiting this sthp
antibody binds on the top so I don't
know okay alright so well then we did of
course is to in fact or transfect head
to nine three cells with the plasmid
that could encode this project and
obtain evenings from them and if it all
works out and these evenings would
exhibit on their surface this antidote
to Nick on the anterior to s CF v and as
you can see if you look at the blue
arrow on the blue one there is a
schematic representation of a yellow
represents it in yellow and it has drew
norms sorry green knobs on top this
represents the SDS me and
body and honesty area student body and
the red part are the c1 c2 domains
okay so you know we made this in this
way directly from transmission but also
made it by purifying this person
remember he was the histogram and mixed
naive Ibiza music change from non
prospected cells which is the
illustration to the right of this chart
and when we did that we found that you
know the resulting even said crystal
affinity for targeting because you
receptor I guess because you know there
was a most saturation via the coverage
was more complete when this method was
used and if you look at the graph the
bar graph it shows you that and we used
Eliza to do this very standard technique
that both the transactions V's movies
change my transfection
which is the sort of yellowish bar you
can find they can point the virtual
receptor but the binding of the
reconstituted v's is much greater that
is the sort of dark brown bar okay so
they can bind the receptor but what
about the BT 474 cells dia or two
pausing themselves do they have a
predilection to bind the the cells that
are exhibiting this this receptor do
they have a direction for it and can
they avoid it they go to negative and
the answer is yes we did flow cytometry
and you need to look only at the part of
to your right and you can see that again
the that the dog
slide there the dark bar down ground bar
shows you the binding of the of the
directed Indies to hurt you positive
cells and the blue bar the extreme left
is binding to go to essentially go to
negative cells and cf7 do not express
the hood receptor and you can see that
it is not binding and then you also
showed that if you mix the two the
interference by the negative cells is
not free so the two mine they are
directed and they bind specifically
divert the positive stance okay great
but then we have to use them to deliver
our gene and here we decided not to use
the na which is what I told you that one
reason that the test had failed
was that the amounts of the gene
expression was inadequate and one reason
for that is the DNA really is highly
inefficient for genes in every purposes
now if you introduce it into a cell in
order to be converted into a protein it
has got to get into the nucleus
transcribe there come out of it and then
have be translated into the protein this
whole process is highly inefficient
particularly in tumor cells so we said
okay we dispense the use of DNA we use
directly messing with our messenger RNA
that encodes are improved enzyme okay
that's great but you know these are
small destructions and our efforts and
many other their first may find any
other people to Rhodes TVs with an
exogenous mRNA you think are gonna money
initially did not see but we did succeed
in the end and this was done in
collaboration with system Biosciences by
using their exposure plasmid in this
less made we crowns are the enzyme and
protein the CH are all
who sees a lot enzyme gene and also in
front of this the gene we ligated we put
in front of it a 25 nucleotide sequence
which is called a zip code this sequence
was delivered you know
Eevee's obtained from v's that are
generated by all kinds of cells they do
contain mRNA of their own I'm talking
about the difficulty of putting
exogenous and Majdanek the endogenous
ones do getting and so what people did
was to sequence these endogenous him our
lineage and they found that many of them
had to spend five nucleotide sequence
and they dubbed it the zip codes and so
we put two copies of the zip code in
front of being of the gene and when we
use this plasmid to translate
technologies under indeed make TVs that
contained HGH are our state's mRNA is
determined by PCR okay so now we have if
you look at the at the diagram at the
top of the right side you can see a
yellow structure which represents the
evening containing among initially it is
loaded with mRNA and then we mix this
with the EVs reproaching the protein
that the chimeric protein litter no
targets and make them publish it and so
we will change loaded and directed BBS
and these we call Exodus all right so
are these eggs that's capable of
rendering her to positive cells
competent to activate the pro drug see
no and you know testing this became very
easy again because of the fluorescence
of MCS be all we had to do is just add
seen all the see if your lessons of
generation and you can see
in the lower the bond margin mark whose
margin is read that indeed when you you
know the fluorescence is generated when
virtual positive cells are exposed to
these accidents and are hit but with C
no okay so one question is is this
really transcription you know it may be
that some DNA got into the cells as well
you know so we found that this
capability of the cells to activate C
knob was independent of that genome I
Cindy which means no transcription was
required so no DNA is involved and also
that it was eliminated by the protein
inhibitors inhibitors cyclohexyl E which
means that that translation was required
so it from the perfect and it is indeed
mrna that we have succeeded in putting
into the contrapositive cells which then
generate the enzyme and acquire the
capability of activating the culture
good so this is all in vitro about the
crux of the matter how do these extra
tips and see no X in a in vivo situation
so you know we did each one takes a
statistically significant number mice we
implanted in these mice human culture
positive tumors and this was done was a
topically meaning bite on the face and
we treated them with these X attempts
let's team up and I think all you need
to do is look at this
the blue curve you know on your left
graph and the blue curve at the very
bottom shows you so you know the tumors
had grown there and be spotted freaking
the tumors at the current attained
180 millimeter cube size and
when the complete treatment was given
you can see that there was near complete
arrest of the growth of the children so
it's you know really highly gratifying
result and all the controls which are
shown by other graphs there went on to
develop the tumor so this was for
Nadia's success and on the right side by
another 12 you are seeing the tumor
growth rate which essentially is the
same results okay so this is all of this
is done in immune compromised mice but
we think that in a new confident
situation that the therapy can even be
more effective and the reason is that
you know when when the tumor is admitted
inside the mouse in the case of human
beings it's also with them the curd to
protein is released and it would
activate the immune response and it has
been shown that it does optimally you
know it does activate T and B cells
responses and in fact and by the way
this one has been done in collaboration
with our people there are fellow
scientists at University of Indiana and
a nice book so the fact that the her2
receptor protein can evinced a
protective response against the her2
positive coma is shown in these in these
graphs if you look at the left month
what it is showing is the the exhibition
of the noon response you know you're
doing by ellipse on in things like any
major cytokines production and such and
you can see that in all the control we
shall see or to your left there is no
immune response but when the vaccination
system or vaccination is done with the
whole to need to peptide
amounts of Indian response and this is
further shown by the sector in this
mouse model that they have which is
really a very nice mouse model and I
will give you a little bit more detail
of these mice spontaneously developer G+
Sherman but if you vaccinate against her
too
you know in the early stages of breast
cancer then you can utterly choose them
from the development of of humans
whereas in the that is shown by their by
the green and red line on the cross to
your to your fight in the controls that
you must develop in the sort of way that
you would expect when there is no
immunity against them so let me now tell
you a little bit about this mouse model
it has it a mutation in the her2 gene
called her to Delta 16 and it is in this
gene can be induction in the control
whenever you want and what happens is
that upon induction these mice develop
culture positive tumors very rapidly so
what we are doing now is testing our
therapeutic regimen in this in this
setting as I just showed you with the
vaccination the mice even after
induction did not develop the to knows
but this is useful this is effective
only if the treatment is found in the
early stages or before the tumor cancer
develops once it is developed this
therapy alone is not enough and that is
why a combination of this approach
logical effective that's our therapy you
think can be quite helpful okay
the other thing which is very useful and
depression is the fact that he risk and
cross the blood-brain barrier you are
seeing here did not plant area
the dead are the rescued nature and
yellow are the Indies and you can see
that many of them have crossed in and
number of them however get stuck which
means that we do need to improve their
capability to cross the blood-brain
barrier and as you know metastasis to
the brain especially in very positive
concern and in many other cancer is
really the the main issue that is also
in morbidity and mortality and of course
many of the brain diseases also
overexpress receptors and one could use
this approach and this is illustrated
here so for instance you know as you saw
we reconstituted our EB by adding the
purified pH P protein but we can also
instead of having that NTS B at me in
front of the c1 c2 domain we can put
other targeting ligands and some of them
are mentioned shown on the left of your
slide and they have the capability of
promoting transfer of Ibiza cost value
so this is something we are working on
and we hope to be able to see now or in
a recent work we have improved the
prospects of translation of this
approach to the clinic instead of
classmates we have now used in vitro
synthesized mrna reason is the plasmids
you know can introduce all kinds of
nasty things into communities and who
knows won't get that my to and the
patient and we also found that when we
did that the TVs contained much more
mRNA then was the case with the pleasant
and also we have used
54:13 Zika that I have mentioned in the
intro and the reason is that as you saw
it has been tested in clinical trials
and as a result a safe human those when
this has been established this is not
the case with Chino and since our enzyme
ACH rr6 is equally good at activating
trusted people I was thinking 1954 we
decided to do this and as a result you
have successfully been able to use his
IV t mrna eggs with it that is eggs with
depth
it contained that contain my linear
synthesis individual plus C in 1954 and
this was achieved at 220 finessed number
of feedings and was the case with the
plasma TVs and again we found you know
complete rest of the tune growth I'm not
presenting those data but this is a
paper that we had just submitted and you
know they would be copyright issues and
such and in collaboration with Stanford
and existential scientists we are now
preparing during the world for IND in
evening non-clinical pharmacological
continent and toxicological studies
which can be hope will need to first in
human phase 1 clinical trial this is the
last slide and this very long antic
thank you dr. Mann for that informative
presentation I would also like to thank
lab roots for making today's educational
webcast possible before we go I want to
let everyone know that this webcast will
be available for on-demand viewing
through April of 2019 as a final
reminder our speaker will follow up with
any questions you submitted via email
that's all for now thank you for joining
us and we hope to see you again soon